[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui le burundi après
quinze ans de présidence de pierre grise
à une nouvelle page se tourne dans
l'histoire burundaise du moins dans le
domaine diplomatique
alors à quoi ressemble le burundi de la
praye couronnes 10 a très vite après son
investiture le nouveau président
evariste ndayishimiye rompt avec l'
isolement diplomatique du burundi dans
un nid guinée équatoriale egypte
ethiopie
il s'assure du soutien de la plupart des
partenaires régionaux et cherche à
renouer les liens avec l'union
européenne qui a arrêté son aide
financière directe au burundi en 2016
pourtant c'est avec son voisin le rwanda
que les choses patine la pomme de
discorde est le sort de certains
réfugiés burundais que le gouvernement
accuse d'avoir participé à la tentative
de coup d'état de 2015
kigali refuse de les extrader au burundi
malgré les demandes répétées de son
voisin sur le plan interne la situation
reste compliquée pauvreté chômage
corruption
le nouveau président d'haïti mier semble
garder à peu près la même approche du
pouvoir pourtant des signes positifs
apparaissent sur le plan de la liberté
de la presse
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur le gouvernement burundais
actuelle en place depuis juin dernier
c'est le blitz en mai 2020 evariste
ndayishimiye remporte élections
présidentielles en bénéficiant du
soutien du président sortant pierre
nkurunziza au pouvoir depuis 15 ans
membre des forces de guérillas hutu
pendant la guerre civile
dai chi minh et a occupé plusieurs
postes sous couronnes 10 à ministre de
l'intérieur et de la sécurité publique
chef de cabinet civil et militaire
une fois au pouvoir l'alchimie et promet
de tourner une nouvelle page dans
l'histoire burundaise pourtant la
composition de son gouvernement démontre
que la rupture avec le passé n'est pas
évidente
les cadres de l'époque couronne isa
occupent les postes gouvernementaux clés
par exemple alain guillaume bunyoni
désigné comme premier ministre
ou bien le général dira qu'au bout cas
comme ministre de l'intérieur chef du
renseignement sous couronnes 10 1 ce
dernier a mérité durant la guerre civile
le surnom de daqouq garric a
littéralement je vais ttendre raidement
dans son discours d'investiture le 18
juin date chimier promet une série de
réformes internes et une revitalisation
de la diplomatie burundaise et si les
relations avec certains partenaires du
burundi connaissent un dégel à
l'intérieur du pays les choses semblent
plutôt figée
une situation qui se complexifie pas un
équilibre délicat entre deux principales
ethnies les hutus majoritaire et les
petits minoritaires l'époque de
couronnes 10 ha est bel et bien terminée
au burundi or son héritage est encore la
tension ethnique crise économique
isolement international
le président actuel evariste
ndayishimiye tente tant bien que mal
d'améliorer la situation
or traits d'un an après sa prise de
fonctions le bilan reste mitigé car d'un
côté il réussit peu à peu à ramener le
pays sur la scène diplomatique
en renforçant les liens avec plusieurs
partenaires bouron des dans la région il
s'assure aussi du soutien de la russie
et de la chine et entame un
rapprochement avec l'union européenne
de l'autre côté la tension reste
palpable avec le rwanda
celui ci les refusant d'extrader les
réfugiés bout rond dès que le
gouvernement soupçonne de la préparation
du coup d'état de 2015
un interne la situation économique ne
s'améliore pas et le climat sécuritaire
reste tendue
les fantômes de la guerre civile qui a
eu lieu en 1993 sont toujours présents
dans les relations entre les hutus et
les tutsis
quel est donc l'ampleur de la crise
économique et sociale au bourg on dit
quels sont les défis qui se dessine
devant dale chimier à l'international
quels sont les pays qui tendent la main
au nouveau président pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons mathieu merino
chercheur associé à l affaire et est
spécialiste des questions politiques et
environnementales en afrique
messieurs merino bonjour bonjour
tout d'abord parlons ou du nouveau
président evariste ndayishimiye
représente y selon vous la continuité
par rapport à l'époque de couronnes 10
ha ouais c'est un nouveau souffle pour
le bourg ont dit oui c'est une très
bonne question je dirais que c'est c'est
la continuité dans la nouveauté en fait
continuer parce que c'est la même équipe
si vous regardez le premier ministre liu
ni regarder le qui est le lot
aujourd'hui le ministre des affaires
étrangères monsieur linh guiraud un
également au ministère de l'intérieur
d'irak au bout cas par exemple si on
regarde c'est un peu la même équipe chez
les personnes clés du cndd fdd donc le
parti au pouvoir le parti présidentiel
s'est souvent des gens issus du maquis
ils sont au pouvoir depuis les années
ça c'est pour la continuité mais il ya
quand même temps on peut parler de
nouveau souffle certainement parce que
les postes ont bougé il ya quand même
certains postes-clés où on a vu
apparaître de nouveaux personnages et là
on se rend compte que cette nouvelle
équipe est là entreprises surtout une
politique d'ouverture vers l'extérieur
ce qui est très nouveau un ce qu'on
appelle une tentative de normalisation
de ses relations avec l'extérieur
l'ouverture des négociations avec
l'union européenne à ses récentes par
exemple regarder ce ministre des
affaires étrangères qui fait la tournée
des capitales européennes à paris puis à
bruxelles et même le président evariste
qui a fait de nombreux voyages en
afrique
à peine
donc ça c'est c'est en contradiction été
fait sous l'ancienne équipe avec le pire
à une corrida qui avait pas bougé
pendant pas bougé du pays pendant les
cinquante sont son mandat et puis on
peut dire aussi quand je vais prendre un
petit peu de nouveautés on voit quand
même quelques frémissements dans la
politique intérieure alors pas
d'avancées significatives en termes des
droits humains bien entendu mais une
tentative minimes d'ouverture au à
travers des médias qui reste un espace
assez contrôlé mes petits tentative
d'ouverture on libère des prisonniers
alors c'est souvent des prisonniers de
droit commun pas vraiment des
prisonniers politiques je pense que de
2015 ou même les militants du cnl arrêté
pendant pendant le processus électoral
de 2020 mais une promesse a été faite
par le président de libérer plus de 5000
prisonniers
sur les treize mille cinq cent vingt que
compte aujourd'hui le pays je crois que
récemment on a libéré un petit millier
on voudrait monter jusqu'à 5000 bon pour
rappel les capacités d'accueil dans les
prisons bourreaux des sceaux tour de
4200 donc il ya une surpopulation
carcérale mais il ya ces frémissements
ici qu'on peut voir en terme de
d'ouverture à nouveau sous donc les
lignes ont un peu bougé
que pensez-vous des efforts
diplomatiques vous avez cités est-ce
qu'ils réussiront finalement à rompre l
isolement international dans lequel le
burundi se trouvait jusqu'ici je crois
que c'est déjà rompu regardez ce
gouvernement et donc très proactif sur
sur la scène internationale et
essaieront pu en afrique le président
evariste a fait beaucoup de voyages
c'est aussi rompu avec un pays comme la
france
regardez les avancées en termes sujet de
la coopération militaire
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie et puis je crois que le
personnage clé ici grosse erreur
cet isolement international du burundi
c'est vraiment singh le ministre des
affaires étrangères c'est l'ancien
représentant du mouron de 10 aux
nations-unies
c'est un fin connaisseur des arcanes des
relations internationales donc ça c'est
un vrai atout pour lui aujourd'hui
et puis si on doit quand même un petit
peu relativiser je crois il ya quand
même quelques acteurs internationaux de
poids qui danse aujourd'hui cette
ouverture qui est faite au burundi donc
on va voir s'ils vont réussir à rompent
totalement l'isolant isolement pense
notamment à plusieurs ong ou
organisations de la société civile
internationale dont le discours légitime
trouve écho dans certaines institutions
internationales comme par exemple au
sein du parlement européen je vous
renvoie dernièrement à la prise de
position publique d'une quarantaine
cinquantaine de députés européens qui
ont pris position contre le
rapprochement entre le burundi l'union
européenne je vous le rappelle un
dialogue politique s'est ouvert il y à
il ya quelques temps donc on le voit
bien
cette ouverture ne fait pas l'unanimité
au sein de la communauté nationale et ça
sera peut-être une des limites à pour
sortir le gourbi de luz allemand
monsieur merino merci beaucoup
nous allons poursuivre cette analyse
tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouverons à la fin de l'émission
pour plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore dès son arrivée au pouvoir
d'assigner lance une campagne visant à
faire sortir son pays de l'isolation en
premier lieu est rétabli les liens avec
ses partenaires régionaux le 30 mars
evariste ndayishimiye se rend en
centrafrique pour assister à
l'investiture de faustin archange
touadéra réélu à la présidence de ce
pays seuls chefs d'état étrangers
présents à la cérémonie il en profite
pour féliciter son homologue
centrafricain et la sueur du soutien
total du burundi cette réanimation de la
diplomatie burundaise commence en
septembre dernier avec une visite
d'abord en tanzanie puis en guinée
équatoriale en novembre ses déplacements
sont plutôt des succès car ils
promettent une intensification des
échanges commerciaux en plus de simples
visites die chimier tente aussi de tirer
profit des situations difficiles dans la
région il balance notamment entre
l'egypte et l'ethiopie qui se disputent
autour du grand barrage éthiopien de la
renaissance
en février le reçoit à guitté gala
présidente éthiopienne
salez work 0 dès la visite officielle
dure deux jours et abouti à l'adoption
d'une stratégie commune visant à
redynamiser la coopération bilatérale un
mois plus tard die chimier seront en
egypte où il est chaleureusement
accueilli par son homologue égyptien
abdel fattah al sisi
à l'issue des négociations une série
d'accords et conclue dans les domaines
de l'éducation du tourisme et de la
culture la presse locale explique une
telle avancée par l'adhésion supposée du
burundi à la coalition égyptienne contre
le barrage éthiopien de la renaissance
pourtant le chef d'état burundais n'a
jamais énoncer clairement sa position
sur le sujet cet exercice d'équilibriste
est également joué par d'alchimie sur
l'échiquier mondial
car le président bouron des cherche
l'amitié avec bruxelles et washington
mes fleurs également avec moscou et
pékin partenaire de longue date du
burundi en octobre 2020 la diplomatie
burundaise parle d'une nouvelle étape
dans la coopération russo burundaise
notamment dans le domaine énergétique
plusieurs projets sont annoncés par
l'ambassadeur du burundi en russie la
chine quand elle se dit prête à aider le
burundi à développer le secteur agricole
est à augmenter ainsi la production du
puits 20 mars
les deux chefs d'état prône le
renforcement des liens bilatéraux
et si les relations avec la chine et la
russie se développe plutôt bien les
relations avec l'union européenne et les
etats unis sont plus complexes en 2015
ses deux plus gros donateur du bourg ont
dit lui tourner le dos lorsque l'ancien
président pierre nkurunziza décide de
briguer un troisième mandat en défiant
les règles de la constitution
washington et bruxelles sanctionna leurs
quatre personnalités proches de
couronnes 10 à angers l'an leurs fonds
et en leur interdisant de voyager sur
leur territoire
2016 bruxelles couple aide financière
directe au gouvernement burundais
un coup dur pour le pouvoir en place qui
perd son principal bailleur de fonds et
voit s'envoler les 430 millions de
dollars prévus sur cinq ans dès sa prise
de fonction dai chi minh et fait tout
son possible pour redémarrer le dialogue
avec l'occident
pourtant washington semble ne pas être
convaincu es prend une position plutôt
attentistes l'union européenne quand
elle fait ses premiers pas en vers le
burundi le 2 février le chef de la
délégation européenne et le ministre
burundais des affaires étrangères s'il
ya un communiqué prévoyant la reprise
des relations bilatérales selon la
diplomatie burundaise
les sanctions pourraient être levés vers
la fin de l'année
malgré les avancées sur le plan
diplomatique d'alchimie et fait face à
de nombreux défis
les relations avec le rwanda reste
tendue alors que la situation en interne
se complexifie de plus en plus quelle
est la gravité de la crise économique en
cours
quels sont les sujets qui opposent le
burundi à son voisin rwandais
pourquoi les tensions restent elles
vivent entre les deux principales
ethnies du pays
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
lutte contre la pauvreté et la
corruption ainsi qu'une série de
réformes internes
evariste die chimier promet des
changements radicaux pourtant
tiendra-t-il sa parole en tenant compte
de l'état déplorable dans lequel son
prédécesseur a laissé le burundi après
la période coloniale
le burundi obtient son indépendance en
dès le départ le pays connaît de fortes
tensions ethniques entre la majorité
hutu qui représente un peu moins de 85%
de la population et la minorité tutsi
environ 15%
ces derniers qui forment
traditionnellement l'élite dirigeante du
pays parviennent tout d'abord à
conserver le pouvoir et l'armée
cependant des réformes démocratiques
nécessité par les tensions
interethniques entraîne élections en
1993 d'un président hutu qui sera
assassiné la même année par des
militaires tout si le coup d'état
réinstalle alors à pouvoir tutsi et une
guerre civile meurtrière se déclenche
elle va durer près de dix ans et coûté
la vie à environ 300 milles personnes le
nombre de réfugiés s'élève à 1,2 million
le premier pas vers la paix est franchie
en 2000 le gouvernement l'opposition
politique et plusieurs groupes armées
rebelles signent un accord de paix à
arusha prévoyant une transition
démocratique et le partage du pouvoir
entre les deux ethnies
cependant les combats vont se poursuivre
avec certaines factions non signataires
de l'accord
en 2003 le principal mouvement rebelle
hutu le cndd fdd dépose des armes en
échange de 4 portefeuille dans le
gouvernement de transition issu des
accords
devenu parti politique il remporte en
2005 les élections législatives et son
chef pierre nkurunziza devient président
l'équilibré ethnique dans l'armée et la
police est respectée et la composition
du gouvernement obéit à la règle de
partage des postes négociés haoussa le
pays commence à connaître un certain
apaisement surtout à partir de 2008
lorsque le dernier mouvement rebelle
hutu signent un accord de cessez le feu
en 2010 le parti du président remporté
une très large victoire aux élections
communales
les partis d'opposition qui estime que
la fraude a été massive décident de
boycotter les élections législatives et
présidentielle pierre nkurunziza seul
candidat est alors réélu président et
son parti obtient une écrasante majorité
au parlement
il renforce son pouvoir alors que les
partis d'opposition subissent des
intimidations ainsi que certains
journalistes ou activistes une loi
restreignant les libertés de la presse
et voter en 2013 les tensions internes
se ravivent à nouveau lorsque le
président envisage en 2014
une réforme de la constitution qui
risquerait notamment de remettre en
question le partage du pouvoir entre les
deux ethnies
le principal parti tutsi good prawna
décide alors de se retirer du
gouvernement provoquant ainsi une crise
politique
elle couronne 10 à des cibles se porter
une nouvelle fois candidat en 2015
contrairement aux accords d'arusha qui
limite à deux le nombre de mandats
présidentiels
cette candidature entraîne des émeutes à
bujumbura et des dissensions au sein
même de son propre parti
une tentative de coup d'état est
organisé en mai 2015
un ancien chef des services de
renseignement le général godefroid
niyombare et mais le président parvient
à reprendre le contrôle de la situation
il va alors se lancer dans une féroce
répression contre ses opposants
les violences font de nombreuses
victimes et des centaines de milliers de
réfugiés
en outre les forces armées sont la cible
de purge visant principalement les
tutsis ce qui remet en cause les
équilibres ethniques en leur sein en fin
de compte elle couronne ziza et réélu en
juillet de la même année
dans ce contexte plusieurs mouvements
d'opposition armée secret dont certains
basés en dehors du pays contribuant
ainsi à l'instabilité de la région
à la surprise générale le président
décide fin 2010 9,2 ne pas se porter
candidat aux élections présidentielles
prévues l'année suivante son successeur
désigné et varicent end et chimie et est
élu le 20 mai 2020 quelques semaines
plus tard le gouvernement burundais
annonce le décès inopiné de pierre
nkurunziza à l'âge de 55 ans à la suite
d'un arrêt cardiaque
l'époque couronnes 10 ha est
officiellement révolue mais peut-on dire
que le burundi a vraiment tourné la page
l'arrivée du nouveau président fait
certes bouger les lignes
sur le plan diplomatique mais j'y reste
des plaies ouvertes comme celle qui
empoisonne les relations entre le
burundi et le rwanda
elle se dégrade en 2015 lors du coup
d'état manqué contre pierre couronnes 10
à le burundi accuse alors le rwanda de
donner l'asile à plusieurs des
organisateurs de ce coup d'état
ainsi que d'armes et et d'entraîner des
rebelles hostiles à son régime comme le
groupe r d tabara par exemple le rwanda
rejette ces accusations
de son côté kigali reproche depuis
longtemps au burundi de collaborer avec
des groupes armés rwandais notamment la
rébellion hutu fdlr une escalade à
laquelle le rwanda espère mettre fin
sous le mandat de die chimier dès son
entrée en fonctions surnommé l'ogre
rwandais paul kagamé tend la main à guy
dégâts nous devons tourner la page de
l'histoire
si le président ndedi milliers et ses
collaborateurs optent pour cette bonne
voie et nous trouverons au milieu du
boulevard pour partir ensemble et
consolider nos relations diplomatiques
et nous leur assurons que de notre côté
nous n'allons constitué aucun obstacle
côté bouron des l'initiative est
aussitôt rejetée par le président qui
accuse paul kagame d'hypocrisie pourtant
malgré cette première impression
l'animosité un changement de cap se
profile dès le mois d'août le 13 août
2020 première réunion des représentants
des deux pays depuis des années
parrainée par l'onu elle est en plus
couronnés d'une avancée les deux pays
annoncent un accord sur le rapatriement
des réfugiés burundais depuis le rwanda
le 26 août
nouvelle surprise les chefs de
renseignement burundais et rwandais se
rencontrent à la frontière commune
ils s'engagent à oeuvrer ensemble pour y
rétablir la sécurité sur fond
d'incidents transfrontalier persistant
en octobre c'est au tour des ministres
des affaires étrangères de tenir une
rencontre surprise les diplomates
parlent de l'ouverture d'un nouveau
chapitre et assure vouloir résoudre tous
leurs différends
pourtant la normalisation ne décolle pas
la pierre d'achoppement reste le sort de
certains réfugiés le burundi réclame au
rwanda d'extrader tous ceux qui
l'accusent d'avoir pris part au coup
d'état manqué de 2015
kigali refuse les prétendus putschistes
conflit au rwanda en tant que réfugiés
et nous sommes contraints par le droit
international dans notre traitement des
réfugiés
cette demande de die chimier s'aligne
sur la position de l'ancien président
pierre nkurunziza
en effet dès le début de sa campagne
électorale le nouveau président promet
de suivre la trace de son prédécesseur
on voit peu cette continuité sur le plan
international mais en interne et les
plus flagrantes
le climat politique au burundi demeure
crispé plusieurs opposants vivant en
exil
craignant des répressions qui se
poursuivent dans le pays
exécutions extrajudiciaires détentions
arbitraires torture voire meurtre des
exactions recensé deux semaines en
semaines inquiète à l'onu
les abus on continue à être commis
notamment à la suite des nombreux
incidents sécuritaires qui ont eu lieu
depuis l'été 2020 le gouvernement doit
reconnaître la gravité de la situation
et y remédier soucieux de son image le
président d'atg imier tente quand même
de redorer son blason
tout d'abord il tend la main aux bêtes
noires de l'ancien régime
les médias indépendants fin décembre le
chef d'état ali ber quatre journalistes
arrêtés en 2019 pour une enquête sur des
affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre burundaise et un groupes armés
congolais
en janvier il s'adresse directement aux
médias sous sanctions et les invite au
dialogue en février après plus de cinq
ans de silence la radio privée bonesha
est de nouveau autorisée à diffuser
or de nombreux médias indépendants
restent bloqués comme renaissance tv et
r faire la pression sur les opposants
est assouplie et le 6 le 8 mars le
président bouron des gras cycle de cinq
mille prisonniers soit 40% de tous les
débuts du pays le but est de désengorger
les prisons surpeuplées qui abrite trois
fois plus de personnes que leur permet
leur capacité pourtant la décision
attire aussi des critiques
en plus d'être lente la clémence de
s'applique ni aux prisonniers politiques
ni aux activistes des droits de l'homme
les changements sont lent et incertain
pourtant la situation des droits de
l'homme au burundi est au centre de
l'attention de l'onu et de l'union
européenne
et l'attitude européenne face au nouveau
pouvoir est crucial pour guetter gars
qui tente d'obtenir la levée des
sanctions de bruxelles une détente dont
l'économie burundaise a cruellement
besoin parce que le burundi est au bord
du gouffre
il figure parmi les trois pays les plus
pauvres
monde selon la banque mondiale 75 % de
la population vit en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
l'économie est minée par la mauvaise
gestion la corruption et l'insécurité
le résultat est une crise humanitaire
qui poussent des centaines de milliers
de burundais à fuir vers les pays
voisins
la crise du comique 19 s'ajoutent aux
mots de gaieté gars en 2020 l'économie
se contracte de plus de 3% le déficit
fiscal frôle les 10% du pib et la dette
publique dépasse 20%
pire encore le burundi vie comme sur un
volcan des acteurs de la guerre civile
sont toujours présents au pouvoir ait
des tensions ethniques couve sous les
cendres dans les milieux politique et au
sein de la population
les ong s'alarment en particulier d'une
possible politisation de ces divisions
par le gouvernement pendant les derniers
mois
il y a eu une montée des discours de
haine pour motif est ni il compris de la
part d'individus proche du gouvernement
en vue de déshumaniser des parties de la
population
pour y voir plus clair nous rejoignons à
nouveau mathieu merino chercheur associé
à la frs spécialiste des questions
politiques et environnementales en
afrique
messieurs merino pensez vous que die
chimier soit à la bonne personne le bon
président pour sortir le pays du gouffre
économique
là je vous avoue c'est un peu difficile
de répondre à cette question parce que
c'est difficile de se projeter
mais on a quelques éléments le burundi
est parmi les pays les 25 pays les plus
pauvres du monde avec des ressources
très faible par habitant mais on le voit
ici je crois il ya deux idées qui
peuvent nous éclairer si on voudrait
tenter de répondre à cette question
c'est peut-être voir la politique
d'ouverture aujourd'hui qui existe des
nouvelles autorités
certainement fait revenir une partie
très enlevée easter pas tous mais une
partie 1 et mais rappelez vous laisser
les ambitions ont souvent besoin de
stabilité alors stabilité politique à
l'intérieur du pays
et ça on n'est pas encore dans un
contexte comme cela au burundi est aussi
une stabilité plus largement régionales
et c'est vrai que le burundi autour du
bourg on dit il ya la rdc il ya le
rwanda donc cette stabilité régionale
n'est pas activement mais certainement
que des investisseurs vont revenir à la
faveur de cette ouverture des autorités
et le deuxième élément qui peut nous
guider ici
c'est que je crois c'est assez nouveau
les nouvelles autorités semblent impulsé
je dirais une politique ambitieuse alors
est-ce qu'ils auront les moyens de leurs
ambitions ça c'est une autre question a
une politique ambitieuse sur le plan
économique
alors est-ce qu'ils ont reçu des
promesses d'allier ou de bailleurs qui
vont pouvoir les financer ses politiques
publiques on voit la politique d' aides
à l'emploi des jeunes je crois que
c'était au tour des 48 50 milliards de
francs burundais
c'est une somme importante pour le pays
ça c'est une volonté du président actuel
est de 100 et son gouvernement alors
c'est un peu le copier coller des
politiques économiques un d'incitation
qu'on a mis en place au rwanda
autour de l'entrepreneuriat alors tout
le monde la poubelle tous les jeunes et
des entrepreneurs au burundi certes mais
c'est une réponse intéressante alors
bien sûr pour que ça fonctionne on sait
très bien il ya déficit en
infrastructures et en éducation au
burundi
cette politique seule ne pourra pas
réussir si gap a en plus une politique
plus large de développement tueur et
dans le pays et je vous le dis il faut
avoir un global et surtout faut avoir
des moyens financiers de le faire
est ce assez c'est la question qui
restera en suspens dit vous avez parlé
de la stabilité
les ong s'alarment pas mal sur une
montée des discours de haine pour motifs
ethniques
ces derniers temps les fantômes du passé
et peuvent-ils resurgir aujourd'hui au
burundi selon vous c'est une bonne
question
écoutez on faut qu'on soit clair oui il
ya une montée de discours haineux du
discours inflammatoires après est ce que
la population va suivre ça c'est
difficile d'y répondre
moi j'aurais tendance à dire non mais on
ne sait jamais c'est moins sûr on va
dire mais pour rappel le je crois que le
référentiel ethnique c'est une ressource
politique qui a été instrumentalisée à
toutes les époques et dans différentes
zones du monde
c'est donc utilisé en temps de crise
qu'elles soient sociales ou économiques
c'est utilisé en temps de compétition
électorale un moment des élections mais
aujourd'hui on le voit au burundi le
clivage hutu tutsi puisque c'est ça
qu'il ya derrière votre question
aujourd'hui on a surtout des conflits
entre personnes de la même ethnie entre
hutu par exemple aujourd'hui ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que
les politiques de prévention et
d'atténuation du discours et ne sont pas
vraiment une priorité des autorités
c'est les efforts sont aujourd'hui
minimes mais du côté de la communauté
internationale on est quelque peu absent
aussi un faut dire que tous les
programmes un peu de autour de la pêche
ont des résultats contestables
aujourd'hui et puis pour finir peut-être
l'histoire est très récente se placer
sur 10 15 20 30 ans est en cours si on
se passe sur un temps l'on se rend
compte que c'est des sujets où il ya
toujours beaucoup d'émotion il ya des
contemporains encore de ces époques où
il ya eu des tensions communautaires
ethnique dans le pays
je crois qu'il faut beaucoup de temps et
là je vous renvoie la trajectoire
historique de pays ailleurs en afrique
ou dans le monde où on met toujours du
temps à sortir de deux de ses fantômes
du passé comme vous dites merci beaucoup
monsieur merino mathieu merino chercheur
associé à la frs paris spécialiste des
questions politiques et
environnementales en afrique nous a
accompagné aujourd'hui dans cette
émission merci encore
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]